At the beginning of fourth grade,
I joined Peer Helpers.
Peer Helpers is an inclusion program
where students like myself
can interact with students
in Special Education.
When I joined, I was looking to try
something new
because, you see, at my elementary school,
there's only chess club
and Peer Helpers,
so my options were pretty limited.
But the kids that I did see peer helping
looked like they were having tons of fun.
I mean, they were missing class,
sitting together at lunch,
and taking trips.
I wanted in on that, so I joined.
At the time, I had no idea I would
eventually be meeting someone
who would become
one of my closest friends today,
Henley Hager.
When I first met Henley and his family,
it was a disaster.
I vividly remember talking
to Mrs. Hager for the first time,
and I had no idea what to say.
It was probably something like,
"Hey, Mrs. Hager, I'm here
to work with Henley."
So after I introduced myself to her,
I finally met Henley,
the boy I was going to be working with.
At first, I didn't know
what to do or say around Henley.
You see, Henley has severe autism,
and I had no experience working with
anyone like that before.
I'm going to be honest.
It's not like I just strolled in there
and was already best buddies with him.
I was nervous,
nervous that I might set him off,
or nervous that I might do something
to upset him,
and since we're being honest,
I was nervous because we as humans
have a tendency to feel uncomfortable
around people who are different than us.
Regardless, over the next three years,
every Wednesday, I went with Henley
to an after-school program
where we would on social
and academic skills,
such as organization,
doing homework,
physical exercise,
calming down,
helping him understand the day's plan,
not complaining
when he doesn't get his way,
and engaging in small talk.
But as long as I've known Henley,
I know what he wants to do,
play on the computer.
But we can't always do that.
So I'll provide other examples
of what we can do,
like walk around the track,
use the stationary bike,
or play basketball.
He'll answer with yes or no,
or he's gotten to the point
where he will politely ask
if we can do this activity instead.
Over the years, Henley's small talk
has greatly improved
and it's not just with me,
it's with every person he interacts with.
That's one of the goals
of inclusion programs.
Inclusion programs benefit people
because they develop friendships,
increase achievement of IEP goals,
and greater opportunities for enhance
learning are formed.
But apart from all that,
we would go fun places.
I remember one time, Henley and I
went to the McWane Science Center
in Downtown Birmingham.
We had fun watching the fish,
and stingrays, and sharks.
But imagine being at the science center
and hearing two teenage boys cracking up
and giggling over nothing.
Henley and I can just let out
a quick giggle
and the laugh attacks begin.
I have the best time ever
when I'm with him
and I always look forward
to spending time with him,
but this trip wasn't me
being his Peer Helper.
These were just two best friends
hanging out and watching sharks.
Now, I can talk about how much
I've done with or for Henley,
but what I really want you to hear
and what rarely gets mentioned
is the fact that Henley
has also helped me.
He's helped me become more patient,
I am better at working with kids
with disabilities,
and I believe I've become more
compassionate
toward those different than me.
So through my interactions with Henley,
I mentioned becoming more patient.
For example, Henley takes longer
to learn certain concepts,
to do school work,
and to respond to certain questions.
And because of this, I've learned to
repeat myself without getting frustrated,
or at least making
that frustration visible.
Somebody should teach my mom that.
But let me be clear.
Many times it was frustrating,
but you can't get mad at him
because he's not intentionally
trying to be difficult.
He's just taking his time and adjusting
to the task at hand
the best way he knows how.
Understanding this has made me
a more patient person
in all aspects of life.
And apart from patience,
I've become better at working
with kids with special needs.
In your everyday school,
a majority of students pretend
like students in the Special Ed department
don't even exist.
They walk through the halls,
talk to their friends,
and ignore those with special needs.
Rarely do people interact with these
students in a positive and helpful way.
But I've learned that through
interacting with students like Henley,
when you ignore those with
special needs,
you're missing out on a gift.
So from fourth to seventh grade,
I worked exclusively with Henley,
and that partnership,
that friendship,
is one of the best things
that has ever happened to me.
I have loved working with Henley,
and becoming a Peer Helper
was one of the best decisions of my life.
But sadly, not all students
have this opportunity.
After researching, I was shocked
to find that people with special needs
do not have enough, if any,
Peer Helpers in their school.
And what's worse, not all schools
provide enough teachers or teachers' aids
to students in the special ed department.
So get ready for this part.
Many students in the Special Ed department
don't receive the adequate services
they deserve.
And of the schools who don't provide
the adequate services to these students,
I believe the most common reason
is because they don't have
enough funding or staff,
but if they're not up to standard,
it's the students who suffer.
Think of all the kids
with learning disabilities
and how they need help
to thrive in their learning.
Without it, jobs may not
be available to them,
or they may not learn social skills
needed to live in the environment
we live in today,
their autonomy won't develop
and these rich relationships
will not be formed.
All of these concepts rotate
around each other,
and are things that I work with
Henley to improve on.
I can tell that Henley
has greatly improved
with communicating with
people throughout the years,
and this is because he's fortunate enough
to live in a community
that has a very respectable
Special Education program
with many staff members
and a thriving Peer Helper program.
But, like I said before, not all schools,
a majority in fact,
adequately support the Special
Education department,
which is making it harder for these kids
to become the most successful version
of themselves.
But now, let's say schools
do start providing
the help they should
be giving to these kids.
Let's say that these students thrive.
I mean think of the possibilites.
They'd be prepared for the work force,
and they'd learn stronger social skills.
If the schools are not providing
enough teachers or teachers' aids
to students in the Special Ed department,
I say that job is passed to us,
the students.
I say the students should step up
and support their fellow classmates.
Every student in here
has the ability to help.
The hardest part is acting on the problem,
but I know everyone can do it.
One of the best and most effective ways
you can help Special Education departments
is by creating or joining
a Peer Helper program.
Once you join of these programs,
you'll feel like a different person
because you realize how much of
an impact you have on other individuals.
Because helping others impacts you.
It turns you into
a "glass half full" person
and essentially, build stronger
friendships with those who need it.
So aside from lunch, being a Peer Helper
is the best part of school by a landslide.
For those of you who enjoy learning,
just wait until you become a Peer Helper.
Every Tuesday and some Thursdays,
I help,
and when I get to school, I am so excited.
I'm excited for the time of day
I can walk into that room
and say hello to all my friends
who I enjoy helping.
Becoming a Peer Helper should
be considered a privilege
because not only are you positively
impacting your fellow peers,
they also help you,
and you'll build
long-standing relationships
from this as well.
It is hard work sometimes, and you're
definitely not going to get a trophy
saying you're a good Peer Helper.
But really who needs a trophy
when you're gaining a friend?
That's the best reward.
Being a Peer Helper helped me
realize who I am as a person
and my purpose in not just my life,
but other's lives too.
So I challenge my fellow students
in the audience
to strongly consider becoming
a Peer Helper.
You will love it.
And if you don't have one, talk with
your principal or Board of Education
and make one because these
students really need it.
And to you parents listening out there,
encourage your son or daughter
to participate in Peer Helper programs
because all it takes is eight words to
change your life and the lives of others,
"I would like to become a peer helper."